it happens particularly with dictators
who've uh claimed to be field Marshals
or whatever by putting on a uniform
um like mabutu in Zaire or Saddam
Hussein uh in Iraq without actually
having any particularly relevant
experience but if they put on a uniform
they think they can give orders
precisely because of the way they've
come to power uh they're nervous about
uh people coming to power in the same
way so instead of looking for
professional competence in their leaders
they look for loyalty instead and
sometimes this can be absolutely
disastrous because
um
with maputo for example it was uh in the
end he only really trusted relations uh
uh with with Saddam it had to be members
of the bath party
and this and eventually when they get
into war that happened with Saddam in
the war with Iran that went on for much
of the 1980s he was losing
and he suddenly realized he actually did
need people who understood how to run
armies in charge another example as
president two in in South Vietnam
um who uh didn't even want to see Senior
generals to confer with one another
unless they start plotting when they did
because there's been a succession of
military coups which is how he got to
power uh so uh it's an important aspect
of why authoritarian regimes not all of
them but uh often fall often fail is is
because
um that they don't trust the generals to
get on with fighting Wars rather than
plotting to take over the government
yes I mean very much thinking of the
shade of Joseph Stalin who purged his
officer call before the second world war
but fortunately for him in 1942 he
realized that actually political hacks
do not necessarily make better generals
than professional soldiers and you have
this kind of grotesque spectacle of
people actually like rokusovski being
pulled out of Gulag labor camps and
saying you know with a sort of
metaphorical whoops here's your uniform
you are now in command uh of of a front
or whatever
but that that point you're making is
something that comes up in the book
which which sounds very
counter-intuitive is precisely that in
fact democracies are better War fighting
engines
than dictatorships and it is precisely
because of this issue of what checks and
balances and a concern about uh not you
know trust not trusting your own
soldiers
yeah I mean democracies as we know can
make big mistakes so uh it doesn't
guarantee uh that they don't make a
necessary moves into Warfare but they
have an ability to adjust and adapt
thereafter uh there are checks and
balances whereas I think the problem
with with dictators uh autocrat uh is
that they get surrounded by sycophants
you don't have that sort of still small
voicing are you sure this is a good idea
have you thought about this
um what happens if they do that you
don't have that so they can be bold they
can catch their opponents by surprise uh
but then all the pitfalls that they
might have been alert to uh then catch
them by surprise and I believe that it
becomes hubris and they believe their
their own bravado so
um I think that there are a number of
examples
of uh just as this lack of
self-awareness and you know it is worth
noting
um that though you know Western military
experience uh is has got Vietnam and
it's got Iraq and it's got Afghanistan
these weren't defeats in battle the
these were getting into situations where
you just weren't welcome in the in the
places where you were occupied
um where you get real defeats in battle
that this is often because people assume
that military power can achieve things
for them that it really can't
hopefully again I'm sure there'll be
questions on this topic but if we have
time we'll come to Ukraine properly at
the end of this conversation but as you
were speaking I mean apart from the fact
that you know if I if I had one one
little sort of wish I had wished in fact
there was more about uh the basically
the North Koreans and the North
Vietnamese it's been interesting to see
that but how far again in many ways
you're talking about the war in Ukraine
you are precisely talking about a leader
who on the one hand assumes that he
knows about military matters even though
Putin has
so a little derisory amount of Reserve
officer training when he was at
University which you can talk to any
Soviet citizen of that generation
they'll tell you just how little it was
involved
and yet he puts himself at the fore of
of the planning and determining how he
will fight this war and then you have
President zielinski a man who clearly
also has no real military experience but
is instead willing to adopt his role as
the the political leader the rallying
Force the icon and The Advocate abroad
while he lets his generals be his
generals I mean so it's a real case
study of precisely that that issue about
how societies shape the military
but of course I mean that obviously
depends on the politicians being willing
to accept their role but it also
presumably depends on the military
learning how they're going to interact
with the politicians so they're they're
commanders but they're also Advocates
and that obviously can become a problem
there's a very nice little um vignette
in your book
um I mean you talk about this clearly a
lot also in the context of the French uh
Wars of well let's say colonial wars but
really they were decolonial Wars yeah um
but particularly where's Clark in in
Kosovo and the point when sort of hits
It's a furious response the Secretary of
Defense asked me to give you some
verbatim guidance so here it is get your
expletive deleted face off the TV no
more briefings period well that's it
is there an issue now that we have
also a a kind of a not a generation but
let's say a particular
cohort of Military Officers who
precisely
they do understand the political context
they are media Savvy and they know how
much the camera loves to see some craggy
face guy in camouflage
um and and use that precisely to try and
get the politicians to do what they want
well it is an issue and it's been an
issue uh particularly in the American
system it's happened a bit in the UK but
it's more in the American system there's
one particular example
um in uh when Obama came to power
um and uh he was under pressure to do
something about uh Afghanistan and it
was a difficult one for him because he'd
made a name for himself by denouncing
the War uh in Iraq but he sort of
described Afghanistan as a good War it
actually really he arrived it was
clearly not going very well and
um
uh he he uh Stanley Crystal was was put
in charge General Stanley Crystal was
put in charge of of uh trying to find a
way forward in Afghanistan and he came
up with a plan that was going to involve
did involve tens of thousands extra
troops going to Afghanistan and uh they
all went on television they gave
interviews they leaked stuff to The
Washington Post
um they spoke at conferences all uh
making this the the obvious thing to do
so that Obama began to feel bounced into
doing something he wasn't sure about and
because it was actually because he had
no military experience himself he didn't
feel that able to fight back so that
just led to protracted
um and long discussions and actually a
rather unsatisfactory compromise at the
end whereby they got the troops but only
for a limited time which meant of course
the Taliban didn't have to work out very
hard what they had to do to see this out
they just had to wait so
um
uh that was a very good example of the
of the military uh getting ahead of
themselves I mean you mentioned the
French uh
the colonial was the wars of National
Liberation within the Vietnamese and the
uh algerians
um so in the case of Algeria the French
army felt they'd won that they'd
suppressed the efln that they'd uh uh
using methods that were uh pretty brutal
including torture they they had beaten
the enemy uh and then they found that de
Gaulle who obviously was not short of
military credibility himself who they'd
helped to bring to power
um because the previous when the
previous government looked like renaging
on the commitment to algeri francaise
um they suddenly discovered he was going
to do the same uh and yet another coup
was in the offing so you do get this
sense sometimes of those who are
absolutely committed to the fight
um being absolutely furious with the
political Echelon who isn't giving it
the support that they think it deserves
and if we talk about Ukraine we can see
this happening a bit in Russia
uh at the moment uh so it it's uh so
this sort of in there's a point where
you're not giving advice anymore in
uniform you're moving beyond giving
advice to thinking actually you could do
the job better and that's what needs to
coo 's I'll need to cruise